and before we move to the south america
speaker presentation i want to introduce
louis carniel
lucas is our south america moderator and
also a partner at pine biotech and lucas
if i can see you coming up on the screen
here there you are no there's still so
there he is there he is we'll get you on
the screen here um we're gonna have you
uh go ahead and come out and have you
introduce omnics
training
it's all yours
thank you grant thank you all first i
would like to
thank the academy and all the
participants present here
it's with great honor that i would like
to introduce and represent the
participation of south america in this
event
so i will share my
screen if you all
just a moment
lucas you're muted at the moment
and we lost you
and we'll give lucas a moment here to
come back on dr sakamoto will be with
you in just a minute oh look we got
we're going to come to you early it
looks like lucas has dropped out of zoom
so we're going to go ahead and come to
you luis if you are ready for us
um
well let me see we're trying to get him
back in here so give me just a minute
luis
the fun of zoom
give us just a moment please
all right luis we're going to go ahead
and pull the trigger here i'm not seeing
lucas come back in and we don't want to
sag too long so we're going to talk
about precision
and we all know about being precise in
language or when measuring a board
measure twice right
but precision is a relative thing if
we're going to the moon we may measure
in miles and my woodworking is in
fractions of an inch but precision
medicine in pediatric oncology is the
specialty of our next speaker dr luis
sakamoto dr sakamoto is a medical doctor
with more than 20 years of experience
treating children and adolescents with
cancer god bless you sir his topic is
the state of the art and perspectives
relating to precision medicine and
pediatric oncology louise something
tells me we're not going to be using my
wood shop ruler
hello hi everyone thanks for having me
thanks for the organizer to
for the invitation to
speak a little bit about my
my
my field my my work field that is
pediatric oncology
well i
guess i
let me see if i can
share my screen with you
just a little bit
[Music]
okay
let's see here
are you seeing my screen
yes we are we can see your presentation
just okay okay
okay next
okay
uh
this is a this is
at the talk that we we will talk about
today uh i will
as i
i guess i think
uh
there is fewer
even known attendance here that
are used to deal with children with
cancer so i will i will bring you a
little a few a few informations about
pediatric oncology and
in the second part i i
we will talk about uh
how this
bunch of information that is generated
by the omix platforms uh
are changing the way that we we see the
disease in tube in children
and
how we can use this technology to
improve the efficacy of treatment
in efficacy that i will talk about this
later but after that is already
really good when comparing to adulthood
cancers
so
let's go
why i i guess that there is no
attendant here that is uh used to to
deal with
children with cancer it's because cancer
is a
rare event in childhood in fact
when we compared
the incidence of
of cancer
in adult
adults and
in childhood we can see that the numbers
are
very different and we can conclude that
cancer is a disease
uh
proper from older people
so it's a really uh
comprehensive uh really
understandable that there is no no
attendant here that
used to deal with
this type of disease
uh but uh
this the
childhood cancer
although uh very hair uh is in the
in the
in the high and middle-income countries
uh
is the second leading cause of of death
in fact uh
cancer in childhood only a
is
only lost for the the
i'm sorry
just just a minute
oh okay
in fact a cancer
only lost for the
only lose for for the the accidents as a
leading cause of death
and
the the the major
the most common type of cancer types of
cancers are
that really that are related to a
metabolic
system
uh so we have leukemia that are the most
common and second place lymphomas and in
the third place uh the central nervous
systems tumors
although they are hair diseases
they are in the same way
a quite
very curable diseases
uh
if we
we see
the evolution of treatment
from
the 1970s to 2010 we can see that
there is a a huge improvement
uh
in the efficacy of the treatment and a
decrease in the
in the mortality
especially for acute leukemias and
brain lymphomas and
brain brain cancer and lymphomas
especially non-robotic and hodgkin
lymphomas
so this this type of graph
is
uh
it's a
a a reason for
uh all pediatric oncologists
are very proud of this area of interest
because today we can cure a lot of more
children than not here
uh
so why is important to
to study this this uh this type of
disease uh given that we have a disease
that is quite here
and it it's very curable uh the fact is
uh
when we talk when we are talking about a
a a disease that's very curable
um
we have to think to give back this this
person this child to the workforce to
the society to to the workforce
and as uh
shown as a recent study that's published
in lansing oncology
we
we see that
cancer in the
childhood is a
very common cause of disability and
and
morbidity in adulthood
so
um
we are cure a lot but
at what cost we are hearing
in middle and low-income countries
however we
we can see that this
evolution of efficacy of treatment
is not
as good as in high-income countries we
can see for example
that
uh
the
the usa france australia european uh
countries are far
away and a lot better in terms of
efficacy of treatment than
latin america and
east asia for example
we have a problem with low end middle
middle-income
countries that
in fact we don't know
uh
exactly
how we are treating this this uh these
patients because we don't have a system
of register of cancer that is really
really good and we can see in this graph
that the proportion of patients that are
covered by these
registries of cancer that are
almost
a hundred percent in north america but
in latin america for example it's only
only less than 20 percent
so
we are curing less and even
those with uh
are
are not cured i mean we don't know that
why why why they are not
they are not being cured
uh
as i've shown before uh in that graphic
that
shown the the evolution of efficacy in
pediatric oncology uh
all that evolution was due
uh the improvement of
of supportive care and conventional
chemotherapy known of that evolution was
due
uh the new technology that we have today
uh
and in the past
when when i i we treated for example uh
leukemia in acute lymphoblastic leukemia
all we we did
when we are characterizing that disease
is to
to see the morphological aspect of the
cell
and
try to differentiate differentiate these
cells from another kind of leukemic
cells that are myeloid leukemia so in
that in
in that time we have only the the the
ability
to to differentiate myeloid myeloid
cells from lymphoid cells
with the advent of the immuno
immunophenotyping
we had the capability to
we had the
we we were able to characterize more the
cells in b cells or t cells and to
define
subgroups of leukemic cells
uh
and this is a methodology that is used
nowadays to to make the the conventional
diagnostic of leukemias but with the
advent of the new omix platforms we are
able as you can see in this this graph
we are able to
uh
to separate to
to define
various uh
subgroups of leukemia
leukemic cells that are that have
different clinical uh behaviors and
different prognosis
for example i
i would like to
to
i'd like to
to detail here uh this philadelphia
chromosome positive
acute lymphoblastic leukemia that
in the past has a
a really poor prognostic prognosis but
today with the advent of the tyrosine
kinase inhibitors have a better
prognosis and
with the advent of this on platforms we
were able to identify a group of
patients that are similar to this
philadelphia philadelphia chromosome
positive
patients but
in fact they they
don't they doesn't have they don't have
this this
chromosome altered chromosome
we
uh
now are able to differentiate for
example acute myeloid leukemia from
adults
originated from adults
[Applause]
from acute myeloid leukemia from
childhood
as you can see here the target study
that
is performed is performed in in
in
childhood
as compared to the tcga that was
performed in
in adulthood
uh demonstrate that we have a bunch of
alterations that are totally different
totally different
when comparing children and adults
uh as well the
the genes that are more prevalent as
alterated in in children are not are
are not
almost
almost never out alterated in the adults
and
vice versa
we study another a type of
of of neoplasms that is uh
medulloblastoma that
is a a type of tumor that is quite
common in in childhood it's originated
from cerebellum in the fossa posterior
of the cranium
uh
in the past we are
we are
we were
we are able to
to uh
to classify only with the basis of
histology
uh
but nowadays we
with the advent of the
omics platforms we are able to define
four
groups of patients four groups of tumors
that has
quite different
prognostic
probabilities
uh just to know wnet
tumors
have a survival rate that is
are really really really higher uh when
compared to the group 3 for example that
are the
the group that have the worst prognostic
and the worst survival rates
another utility that we have for this
new technologies is
when we have
some kinds of drugs target tariffs that
are specific to the to
to
some kinds of of of uh
of gene alterations
and uh
we want to see if that alteration
uh
uh
that alteration
indicates the use of of of the of a
specific drug
but to do that we have to
to know if that
of the molecular alteration this is an
actionable target
and what is the action of tub target is
uh
a alteration uh genetic or genetic that
can be used as a diagnostic prognostic
too as well
uh can be predict treatment response
uh
there there are a lot of a lot of uh
uh schemas that to define this
this
uh if the the target is in fact
actionable
and i will not talk about this
right now
but uh
in general we we defined four tires of
four levels of importance to define if
the that target is actionable
and the taiwan is the
that variants that have a strong
clinical significance uh and that's uh
that that alterations uh
implies in the the almost in the
the obligation of use of that the term
the term that the specific drug
uh the tire true
uh is when we have a a
a variant that have a potential clinic
clinical significance but we we don't
have a for example fda approved therapy
for that tyre 3 is that alterations that
have a non-clinical significance and
tire 4 is just alterations that are
probably
passengers alterations that have no
significant clinical significance
i
brought the i brought here a clinical
case just for an example
a case often a male with
a two years old patients with a
diagnosis of neuroblastoma that is a
a type of tumor that
that
originates from the sympathetic system
uh
it was performed the ngs third that
demonstrates that this tumor has a
mutation g26s
in arc gene and the problem is uh to
define if this is this alteration is
clinically relevant or not
uh and if it's relevant if this patient
is a kid that to to to the use of hulk
inhibitors
and we can
nowadays we can use uh we can make use
of
some platforms that are publicly
available one of them
is from the scientu cloud
and what we see here is that in fact uh
there is a description of this mutation
in alk
that already
have this been scribed
uh
in patients with neuroblastoma but we
can see here that the the the
alterations that uh
were described in the arc related to
neuroblastoma are uh
in other regions that
are not this this this uh mutation that
was found in in our patients and the
classic uh r
1275 q that is related to the a alkyl
hyper response uh is is far away from
this alteration that was found in our
patients
uh
just a second let me
just erase this
when we
when we made a search in
another uh
databases we we found that
we found that this these alterations
have no
uh that have have has a uncertain
significant clinical significance
and in the cosmic database we
we found no
uh
no
uh potential target terp to be
that could be
used for this patient so
in this case the
defined
of uh alteration in alp g26s has no
clinical significance